all right we're here we went came all
the way to
sochi russia to play each other play
each other exactly okay but to be fair
eric is here on official photography
stuff for fide and i'm charlie i'm the
official photographer for
world cup yep and i got knocked out of
the world cup
on round one but you got to play which
is awesome yeah
let's go so that's all that matters yeah
so now we're going to play more kind of
casual
otb chess yeah we've never played with
tv i've never met you
we only met like for the first time
three days ago exactly
so honestly this is gonna be exciting
okay good luck
good luck oh wait oh white moves first
yep
and we're playing with tiny pieces so
this is going to be
a challenge not to knock things over
it's the perfect chest
for chat didn't you play this against my
shoulders
that's what i'm gonna play against you
because you play knight f3 okay i'm
gonna play
oh novelty oh no
you know this entire opening i only
remember this one line i didn't look at
a single of the line in this
i have no idea how to play it this is my
my bread and butter from like five years
ago
brown butter from five years ago it's
kind of still
but it still tastes good do i know
theory no
not at all don't know for black don't
know for
you know how the pieces move wow you
know i'm better than the kid that sits
next to us also know how the pieces move
but like
wait there's a kid sitting next oh okay
over there
let's drink what's that though
you should tell the online audience what
you're drinking
what are we drinking i ordered whatever
you got
i'm not entirely sure mango passion
fruit chia seed
a mango passion fruit chia seed
that sounds pretty good
okay let's be aggressive i don't like it
i hate being attacked i like it
somebody doesn't like it at least one of
us likes it exactly yeah
okay i'm looking
at yeah
for some reason i was like bishop takes
f6 but if they could have sickling and
take on d5 but i was like wait
it's protected okay i missed that move
i i thought the same thing but okay
let's have some fun
[Music]
oh no my bishop oh no my bishop is not
going to quite work here
all right this is fine
oh wait i need to protect it
by the way this is actually what chess
players do in their free time like at
world events
after olympia it's after a lot of
tournaments after the chess competition
let's just get more stuff we're very
cool people best way to
have some balance in life yeah
oh okay wait a minute is this
is this an oh no my queen woman or am i
missing oh no
wait don't hurt me
okay i can't tell this is actually an oh
no my queen moment or if i'm like
i just trapped my own queen i think you
did i actually think it is
it's gay it's just an ode to bonus the
position matches my shirt
oh true oh no my queen
it's not that bad or is it it's fine
copium wait this is really bad
it's only as bad as you lay your mind to
think it is
yeah it's awful it's awful it's
absolutely awful
oh no oh no
okay you can take my queen
i can take your queen how very kind of
you
you have to treat every blunder as a
gambit
yeah that's why i tell my chat you know
it's never a blunder
it is a dynamic sacrifice it's a dynamic
sacrifice
important life lesson it's all about how
you market it
let's make some moves all right
material so it's not making me feel bad
well i mean when we played our match we
played like a million staff for gambit
that made me
oh no my pawn oh no my pawn
okay it's actually
okay i'll go here
oh wait no ah
i should have gone queen to aaa
it's too late now
oh no my c pawn oh no my seat pawn is
stretching it a little bit
man your rook is so annoying
really maybe
i mean your rook was better than mira
you know the rule that you're not
supposed to
exchange pieces when you're down
material right sometimes i break the
rules
you just incentivized everybody who
watches youtube videos and are 600 to
never follow another opening rule again
in their life and breaking the rules is
different from breaking the law
oh the law okay
[Music]
okay oh my pawn oh no my palm moment
all right we are not taking i almost
actually i looked at it
oh dear i'm feeling more comfortable i
like the
coordination you have like a little
fortress going on
thank you
so
this is getting intense dude my queen is
like hanging in like 10 different ways
here
why don't get forked oh no oh no no no
don't flag oh i didn't see that
i call this the skewer the mushroom wait
what
oh no oh no my pond
okay this is a fascinating position
oh we both have no time
wait what
no no queen is about to be reborn
no i thought i had uh i thought that
queen before
but then your bishop is here bishop's a
very useful piece on v8
and it can move backwards that i forgot
okay the bishop can't move forwards for
the square
i i can't believe i won the queen and he
still lost the game
you you just you outplayed me in that
middle game like
25 was unfortunate but it's still tricky
like bishop at night and then passed
pawn
i mean you just didn't give up right
like that was like i like to fight
yeah that was a good game though hello
to youtube hello to youtube that wasn't
oh no my queen in real life
it was an oh no my queen in real life
exactly he planned all the rest of that
every single part of that i had to think
20 moves ahead there
yes absolutely all right cheesy